>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Joan Weeks: Well, good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the Library of Congress and
to the Noontime Lecture Series
with today's program entitled
Witness, Aleppo, Armerian, Assyrian,
and Arab Music, Stories, and
Images from Pre-war Syria
by Jason Hamacher sponsored
by the Near East division--
Near East Section of the
African and Middle East Division.
On behalf of all my colleagues, I'd
like to welcome you to the series.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the Near East Section
that is sponsoring this program
this afternoon and especially
for our chief, Dr. Mary Jane Dee
[assume spelling] welcome you
and give you a few kind of
overview remarks about our division
and the hopes that
you'll plan at your back
to the research in our collections.
The division is comprised of three
sections and served the collections
to researchers from
around the world.
We cover 75 countries and
more than two dozen languages.
The African Section includes all of
countries in Sub-Saharan, Africa.
The Arab-- Hebraica
Section is responsible
for Judaica and Hebraica worldwide.
And the Near East Section covers all
of the Arabic countries
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
Afghanistan, and the Muslims
in Western China, Russia
and the Balkans
and the people of the Caucuses.
So you see it's a very
wide range of coverage.
After the program, we'd like
to invite you to ask questions,
but this program is being
recorded so please know
that that implicitly gives your
permission to be taped and recorded.
So now, I would like to invite Dr.
Levon Avdoyan who is the specialist
in Armenian and Georgia to the
podium to introduce the program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: Thank you,
Joan and thank you for coming
out on Friday, which is usually the
end of the week and a trial for all
of you to get through
to our reading room.
I want to welcome you to our
division, but I also want
to call your attention
to Ms. Thea Austen who is
from the American Folklife Center
who is cosponsoring this event
with us and we've done many
successful programs together
and it looks like this
is another one.
Why are we doing this program?
Well, I met Jason in
the best of ways.
He came in to the reading room
seeking our reference help
when he was working on an album and
we adore meeting people in this way
because we learn from them.
And I learned from him
also that I could help him
up to a certain point,
but not past that point
and as luck would have it,
a very close friend of mine
who is an Armenian specialist from
Aleppo teaching at Whitman College
in Walla Walla, which
is not easy to say.
Dr. Ellisa Mergion [assume
spelling] was interested
and [inaudible] meetings
and I introduced them.
And the reason I'm saying this is
that to follow what Joan's just
said, we not only help people,
we establish networks for
scholars and hook them
up with resources both
here and elsewhere.
So what was he working on?
Well, he was working on an album
of Armenian chants from the Church
of the Forty Martyrs in Aleppo.
And that was quite interesting.
But what I also found out
interesting was that Jason works
on the musical and photographic
heritage of not just the Armenian's
of Aleppo, but the Jewish
communities of Aleppo.
The Armenian communities,
the Assyrian communities,
the Arabic communities of Aleppo
and those that know me realize
that although I'm an impassioned
researcher of Armenia and Georgia,
I view all of these
cultures together.
We've coexisted together.
We've live together.
We've experienced things together.
So this was an exciting time
because he had already met
that time the Armenian album
but an album on Sufi music.
So it was a good opportunity to
demonstrate exactly what we do here.
Now, as Joan said after Jason
Hamacher's presentation,
there will be, I hope time
for questions and answers.
And also at the back of the reading
room as you leave, there is a survey
for you to fill out if you would
like to live your impressions
to this program on to Jason Hamacher
who is a musician, a photographer,
a documentarian and the owner
of Lost Origin Productions.
He's also a punk rocker, a
rock drummer and has been
so for 25 years in the DC area.
Now from 2005 to 2010 he went
to document ancient
religious traditions
and inadvertently captured
the AIPAC's
of Syria's modernization before
the eruption of the Civil War.
His combination of photography,
sound and personal experience
of the Syria offers an
unparalleled immersion into one
of the world's oldest civilizations.
Hamacher has I am told an adventure
spirit, passion for people and love
of culture and that's earned
him the trust of the Syrian's
across all socioeconomic
classes which allowed him
to truly captured the essence of
the Syrian landscape and its people.
His efforts contribute to the
international conversation on Syria
with frequent television, radio
print and live appearances.
So we're very lucky
to have him today.
He is recently spoken at the
United Nations in Geneva.
He's been a guest at Saint
Mary's Church in Cambridge,
the Armenian Museum and
Library of the United States
and at Dumbarton Oaks Research
Library and Collections.
And he has appeared also on NPR,
BBC World Service, Al Jazeera,
Voice of America-- well,
you get the picture.
I'm going to stop talking and I'm
going to invite Jason Hamacher
to come and address us on a subject
which I find extremely interesting.
And I am going to close
the door, first.
Please welcome Jason Hamacher.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Hamacher: Thank you.
Thank you.
Never in my life would I think I'd
be speaking inside of the Library
of Congress and it is a complete
honor to be in front of you
and share some of these experiences.
So, that was a very
overwhelming welcoming
to actually hear it
spoken in person.
I want to tell you a little
bit about how this happened
and that will explain what I have
and kind of seek the importance
of where it is in the
current state of affairs.
Ten year ago my band broke up.
I was in Arlington and I was really
frustrated with being in a band.
Like, at any job or at any business
you have to rely on the people
that you hang out with,
that you deal with everyday.
Imagine being in a van that
sits 10 people for eight years.
It could be a little rough.
So me and this guy, we grew up.
We grew up together and the-- we
end up pulling the plug and I wanted
to do something new creatively.
I wanted to do something that
took the essence of punk rock
and I will describe that in
a little bit and combine it
with something new and kind of
push the limits of our creativity.
So I wanted to do a symphony.
Thirty drummers, theses
are lofty ideas.
Thirty drummers, 15 guitars,
whatever and do something
that crafted symphonic movements,
not pop songs, but symphonic music
to some ancient vocal
tradition, something that puts us
at the Kennedy Center
instead of the 1930 club.
That was the idea.
And do I'm driving
through Rock Creek Park.
I live in Mount Pleasant
and for those of you
that are familiar that's-- it's
a riven and there's a tunnel,
right before you exit
and go up into the zoo.
And my friend called and said,
"I found these amazing
chants from Serbia."
And what I heard was, "I found
these amazing chants from Syria,"
and totally misunderstood him.
And it reminded me of a book of
a guy named William Dalrymple,
who from what I remembered I read
this book a couple years prior,
found the world's oldest Christian
music in the deserts of Syria.
So Bill [assume spelling]
called said, "Dude,
I found this rod chants from Serbia.
You've got to check this out."
And my response was, "I
never got to go to Syria."
I got cut-off.
He said, "What do you--
no, no, no, Serbia."
I was like, "I know."
It sounded so amazing I never
got to go up in Damascus
and then my phone cut,
because Sprint is not a very
good cell phone coverage.
And so what happened
was I go to this tunnel.
It's maybe about 30, 45 seconds.
I've recall reading a
couple of pages in this book
where this guy describes
allegedly one
of the world's oldest
Christian traditions
and my memory thinks
we've got to rock
out to this ancient Christian music.
So I come to the other side of
the tunnel and I call Bill back.
I said, "Hey, man, remember the book
where the guy finds the
chanting in the desert?"
He's like, "I said,
Serbia, Caucus Mountains."
I was like, "You, you
do your Serbia research,
I'm going to do my Syria
research and I'll hit you
up at the end of the week."
It's like Tuesday or something.
So I go and I get my book out
and I'm flipping through it
and I'm very impatient and
I can't find the two pages
that describe this ancient chanting.
So, I get on the internet
and I find an email address
that I figured would go to either
his publicist or him personally
or the publisher someone to read it.
So I put, you know, these are
the bands that I use to be in
and this is the places
I've been on the planet.
I love this book.
I love to get a copy of the CD.
And so to make sure that someone at
least opened my email in my caption
or my address, I put
potential speaking engagement
in Washington, DC.
And the engagement was speaking
to me on the telephone, right?
That was the way I
was dealing with it.
And so to my shock, he opened it
and emailed me within four hours.
He was in the UK.
He said, "This is great idea.
I don't know where you
can hear this music.
When you go to Syria tell them at
the airport, this is what the--
how you get to the neighborhood of
high Syrian and the city of Aleppo."
He's like, it's not a
monastery in the desert,
it is a church among the
worlds oldest of the cities.
I was like, "I am not going to
Syria to start some rock symphony.
I'm not doing it."
But the twist and this is
where everything changes was
that it wasn't a monastery
in the desert,
it was a Syrian Orthodox Church
in this small neighborhood.
Three years prior, the last tour I
ever did, I took a week off and flew
in the deep Eastern
Turkey with my camera.
I'm a photographer and drove
4000 miles over the course
of six days photographing the entire
historical Armenia, Mesopotamia
and stumbled into the Syrian
Orthodox Church because I wanted
to hear the language of the
Syriac, Aramaic being spoken.
So here we are.
All of the sudden, this music I
want to hear is from this community.
So it was like, I got to email
the archbishop I had launch
with on the planes of Mesopotamia.
So, again, I'm on the internet
and I find another email address
with no corresponding website.
It's info@syrianorthodoxchurch.org.
There is no website for
syrianorthodoxchurch.org.
This is just an email address.
So, same email.
This is the authorized book
to, this is the book I read,
these are the places I've been I'd
love to get a copy of this music.
And then two days later, the
archbishop of the United States
for Syrian Orthodox emailed me back
saying, "This is a fantastic idea.
Next time we're in your-- the next
time you're in New York come and sit
down with me and we
can go over your idea."
I was like, "Oh, OK let's talk."
So I emailed and ask if it would
be OK to talk on the phone.
We had a phone conversation and he
said the music that I was looking
for was one of their oldest
traditions and he didn't have a copy
of it to send me, but he could
send me something similar.
And I said, "Where do I get a copy
of the music that I'm looking for?"
He said, "Well, we don't have one."
I said, "Where do I get one?
I'm willing to pay whatever it cost
to get it shipped from Syria to DC."
He said, "We don't have
a recording to send you."
Its like, "Period, you
don't have a recording.
1800 years you don't have this
recorded and I can't hear it."
He said, "No."
I said, "Do you want me
to make one for you?"
He's like, "What?"
I said, "I'll make a recording.
I can make an album."
I said, "That's my music career.
I can make records."
And he was just like, "Do you--
if you know how, yes, OK."
So then all of a sudden my rock
orchestra goes out the window
and all of the sudden
I'm going to faced
with a potential reservation
initiative and so we had to go
up in New Jersey and came
up with this whole proposal
on how do I record a music, an album
on ancient chants and what does
that mean and why am I doing
it and, you know, everything.
So that is the beginning
of this entire project.
I totally misunderstood someone
and then just started sprinting
into the wind to preserve
the ancient chant of Syria.
And so I was ready to go for the
first time in February of 2006,
which was the same month
that cartoonist did a cartoon
and inflamed the Middle East and
my trip was promptly canceled
and I was told I was potentially
never going to be able to come.
And then the archbishop of Aleppo,
he was the one that was kind
of bringing me and housing me.
I was staying with him.
He called me and said, "I
cannot guarantee your safety.
I have no idea when this will be OK.
I'll let you know."
And so I told my wife,
I was just married.
I've been married a couple months.
I don't think I'm going to Syria.
They have riots in the streets.
And then my wife was like, "Great."
[ Laughter ]
And so in character to the region,
nine days later I get a call,
"Everything is totally fine,
you can come next week."
And I was like, "Wonderful."
So, I arrive and I was confronted
with an image that was one
of the more life changing images
I've ever seen and it was, one,
I was an official guest
of the church.
I didn't know what that meant.
And then, two, no one
came to pick me up.
So, I'm just at the airport.
I cannot speak a leak of Arabic
with my bags and a little bit
of Arabic written down the
address of the archbishop.
So I'm just standing around,
hopefully someone is
going to let me in.
And the reason why no
one came to pick up is
because Bishop Yohanna had gone on
television with the Grand Mufti,
the head of Islam for
Syria, Mufti Hassoun
and together they were denouncing
the riots together in unity
and it was broadcast on television.
They were standing side by side
and it was so striking to me
that this dual attack of
pluralism was something
that was on national television.
It doesn't happen in
a lot of places.
And it was very, very interesting.
And so that was set the tone for
my entire experience in Syria,
all these extremely delicate
centuries old relationships back
and forth and it was
really incredible.
And to be honest as I said,
you know, I'm a punk drummer.
I know zero about the
history of Syria
at the beginning of all of this.
And so the first couple
trips is just me
by osmosis absorbing the
culture, listening to everything,
kind of spending time, a lot of time
with this much people as possible.
And after that first trip in
2006, then I had to get permission
from the Syrian government.
Not a big deal as someone
that's not a diplomat
or any experience politically,
whatsoever.
So I put my proposal together,
fax to Syrian embassy
and called, "Hello.
This is Jason Hamacher.
Do you get a chance to review my
proposal for this project in Syria?"
"No, we haven't."
"OK. When can I call
back to confirm?"
Two weeks.
And I called every
two weeks for months
and months and months and months.
And then a political
scenario happened.
Hezbollah and Israel started
fighting each other and I, again,
not understanding how
sensitive that makes the region.
I called and I said, hey, at
this point we're all first name.
"Jason, how are you?"
"Pretty good.
Get a chance to review
that proposal?"
"No, we haven't."
OK. In the very amount of
fact they not condescending,
the woman that answer
the phone goes,
"Have you been paying
attention to the news?"
I was like, "Absolutely."
"So you know that Israel and
Hezbollah are kind of fighting."
I said, "Oh, yes, yeah."
"So, which means that we are on
high alert and I have no idea
when anyone is going to be
able to review your proposal."
I said, "I totally understand."
And this is verbatim what I said,
"I'll call back when
the war is over."
As it fell out of my mouth,
I realized I was never
going to return to Syria.
I was completely embarrassed
and the woman just goes, "OK."
[ Laughter ]
And so that was it.
It was over.
You know, I knew that that was
just completely embarrassing.
I would never be able to go.
And so I just-- I don't know.
I got to go one time and
see all of these things
and have all these
really nice photos
and then two weeks later I
got a call from the embassy
where someone had read my proposal
by accident and he's father--
one of his fathers best
friends attended this one church
in the one neighborhood in Aleppo
and had just past away and he went
to his funeral and the son went.
And so he was like, "Yeah, I heard
this amazing chant at this funeral
and then I came back to work
and found the proposal trying
to record it on someone's desk."
He's like, "Is this you?"
I was like, "Yes."
He's like, "When can you come in
and meet with the ambassador?"
I was like, "Whenever
you want me to."
And so, that's what led to the next
several phases of this project,
the former ambassador from Syria
to United States invited me over
and because I'm, you
know, a lone wolf.
I'm not official journalist
or representing anyone other
than the sake of preservation.
He kind of green-lit all
my ideas and then one
of the components was I wanted
to photograph extensively
these older neighborhoods
in the City of Aleppo.
And I'll be showing you a lot
of these photographs later.
And he's like, "I'm a big art's fan.
I'd love to see your photography."
I was like, "I didn't
bring any with me."
And so I was invited back
and I showed him my vision
of my first trip and he kind of
tasked me to make a book on the City
of Aleppo and that's
something I've been working
on for the last eight years.
And, at this point, I always
like to say I was never paid
by the Syrian government in any
way, shape or form to do any of this
but far more valuable
for those of you
that are know, he cut
all the red tape.
So, I was given inside access to
all these places inside the city
that most Syrians don't
ever get to see.
And so over the years, things
developed, things developed
and then I made my actual
first recordings in 2008
and this is what it sounds like.
So this-- now, I'm going
to explain why I do this
on record in a little bit.
So this is called "Holy
are you God".
It is from the ancient
tradition of Edessa and this is
from that little neighborhood
inside Aleppo.
[ Singing ]
So at the time of that
recording which is 2008,
five people on the planet
were the masters of this.
That's dramatically dropped.
Dramatically there are five.
There are now three
since this recording.
So that was in 2008.
Those recordings will
be in production
with Smithsonian Folkways.
This album has been in
production for 10 years.
Hopefully, it will come out
within the next year or so.
But, on that first trip in
2006, every single minute
of my time was accounted for.
You know, the archbishop had
me doing everything with him.
One day he had me sit and
remember I cannot speak any Arabic.
I just sat down and he wanted
me to kind of photograph
and see what his day looked
like in the day of meetings.
So, there's a big kind of
grandiose hall, about half the size
of this room, just as high
ceilings and I just sat on the side
and people came in and out all day.
And the first person that came in
was an elderly widow who was asking
for assistance to just
keep her house
because she couldn't
afford it anymore.
One was a businessman who was
coming in to plan financially.
They were building a hospital in one
of the suburbs which you can now see
on YouTube, just being
totally decimated.
To the highlight of the day
was the Prince of Greece.
The Prince of Greece came in who
was his sister is the Queen of Spain
and the bishop thought it was
really funny always to make me all
of a sudden launch into, "Jason,
this is the Prince of Greece.
Tell him what you're doing."
I was like, "What do I"--
I was like, "Forgive me.
What do I call you?"
I'm like, "Is it your highness?
What do I?"
He's like, "I'm Prince Michael."
I was like, "Prince Michael" and
then yeah, I go into these things.
And so it was back and
forth and during the course
of this six hour extent of meetings,
this elderly man walked in kind
of unannounced and it looked
like he was lost, to be honest.
He just kind of sat down
and we're sitting there
and the bishop was speaking
and he broke and just goes,
"This is the leader of the
last Jewish family in the North
of Syria," and he just kept talking.
I was like, "What?"
And so, I was, "Yeah,
nice to meet you.
How are you?"
And so-- well someone had told me
that there is this amazing
historical synagogue inside the city
and afterwards I asked
him about the synagogue.
And, someone's remote control car
is going out of control in the back.
Is my son here?
He's three.
So essentially, the-- I
asked him about the synagogue
and not recognizing the
weight of an official guest.
He felt complied-- compelled to
take me inside the synagogue.
So, in 2006, I got to go in the
ancient synagogue of Aleppo.
The foundation has been
traditionally held.
It was built by King David's general
and the current structure is the
oldest continual used structure
in the entire City of Aleppo.
Meaning, it was never destroyed
and rebuilt-- I take that back.
It was never repurposed.
Meaning, it's 1600 years old in the
dead center of town and that leads
to the second phase of
my experiences in Syria
which was I ended up doing
a photo exhibit here in DC.
at the JCC on '16th
of the synagogue.
A synagogue exhibit, which led to
me working with a Jewish museum,
that's not open yet in New York as
their documentarian and explorer
for all of the Jewish
properties in all of Syria
and the project was the photograph
document and assess what was there,
what's left, what is everything.
And so, I did that
in 2008, '9 and '10.
2010, unannounced the
government support
for that project was totally bold.
So I showed up and I was not allowed
in to anything that
was Jewish anymore.
I was allowed to go.
I could bring all my
equipment but I couldn't go in.
And so I had free time
for the first time
in my six year experience in Syria.
So I started out of boredom
recording all of the places
that I used to walk
by, just my walk.
This is what my day
sounds like in Syria.
And so, the Forty Martyrs Armenian
Church is located in a neighborhood
with the best restaurants, right?
And so I would go there and
that's where I would have lunch.
There's this place called
CC House or Casa Cavalli.
You know, you'll see some of
these photos in a little bit.
And I went in and would asked,
"Hey, I'm-- I've got some time off.
I'm a guest of the bishop.
Would you permit me to come
in and make these recordings?"
So, I made them for no
other reason but just
to kill time walking
around the ancient city.
And that was October of
2010 and then I was going
to return in May of 2011.
And then, I'll never forget
this I was at Del Chess
in Dupont Circle talking with a
friend Inash [assumed spelling].
He was a former diplomat
from the Syrian embassy.
We were talking about how
insane the Arab spring was
and we couldn't believe
how it was happening
and how it would never
happen in Syria,
neither was ever thought
it would happen.
And then, I think it was nine days
later it kicked in and it happened.
and I was in shock as most people.
A part of my shock was not because
of what was happening but was
for the first time in my life, I
was connected to a world event.
That's not something music related.
You know my music community is
real small and it's influential
but it's not world news
in any way, shape or form.
And so all of a sudden--
and I just become a father.
So I have-- at this point,
I'm totally sleep wrecked
because I've got a daughter that's
weeks old and the war has kicked in
and this Smithsonian has
officially accepted the project
and it just keeps getting worse.
And so, in my little Facebook feed,
all of a sudden I'm
getting commercials
for Syria related things,
"Oh, you've typed Syria in.
You would be interested in buying
this or buying that," and it started
to disgust me, to be honest.
That, all of the sudden,
no one had cared anything.
Like, I would try to tell
people, "Hey, I'm going to Syria."
Like, "That's cool.
What else-- tell me something else?"
And so all of the sudden that,
there's destruction happening.
Now it's considered commercially
viable and I'm getting ads
about this on the computer.
So, I stopped working on
everything, to be honest,
in solidarity for what's
still happening.
And so, I stopped working
on the book.
I stopped working on the
albums and all of this
and then it just kept worse and
getting worse and getting worse
and then it came up North
and then it was in Aleppo.
And, now all of the sudden, at first
it was kind of mentioned everyone,
you know, I am like NPR feeds or
BBC or something but now it's on TV.
Now it's on the news.
So people are starting to ask
me, "Hey, didn't you go there?"
I was like, "Yeah.
Remember when I tried to talk to
you about and you didn't care?"
And so, we were-- all of a sudden,
people are now asking me "Is
that what the place looks like?"
I'm like, "No, absolutely not."
And so, I decided to take up,
"OK, I need to finish this book
so I can show people what
this place really looks like."
And so, I have a really good memory
for where I went but not names
of anything, people,
place, anything.
So the way that I do my captions,
I get on Google maps
and I retrace my steps.
I retrace the way I walk and a
friend of mine was on Facebook chat.
He's like, "Hey, I need you.
Give me the name of this mosque
because it's my favorite place."
And as we were trying to figure
this out, the full blown attack
in Aleppo started on the
street and he was like, I--
he's like, "Dude, guns are
going off in my house."
He's like, "We should
probably get off the computer."
And he was like, "If I don't
make it, you're in charge
to show people, to show people."
And so I'm crying because,
again, I'm a punk dude.
I'm not an academic.
I didn't go to college,
which it doesn't make--
it doesn't matter a lot but all
of the sudden, I'm finding myself
in this juxtaposition and I
was like, "Yeah, I'll do it."
He's also a professional
photographer.
His family have-- has been in
the City of Aleppo for 750 years.
They used to be the
governors 500 years ago.
And so, I said, "Yeah, I'll do it."
I was like, "And let's stop the
online chat so you could go hide."
He made it through the night.
Everything is fine.
He's still alive.
And so, everything
changed at that point.
I was like, "OK, it's real.
Let me start doing this."
And so, then it just
kept-- this is 2012.
This is three years ago and
it just kept getting worse
and worse and worse and worse.
A friend of mine came up from
Richmond in 2013 and said,
"You're sitting on a huge archive
of information and you need
to do something with it."
I was like, "I am.
I've got this book.
I've got this album in Folkways."
He's like, "When are
they coming out?
Where can I see them?
How do I learn?"
I said, "I don't know."
He's said, "Do something else."
And so I decided to do what
I've done in my whole life.
I made more records, right?
I started my own record label.
And so, I hadn't listened to any of
these recordings since I made them.
They're just been sitting
in my house.
So, the name of my record label is
"Lost Origin Sound" but the first
of my release it was "Nawa".
This is the Sufi album.
And-- So this album, this is the
first time they ever let a westerner
see them or hear them.
They were practicing outside of
a Sufi lodge in the courtyard
of a 500 year old house
in the ancient city
and this is one of
my favorite albums.
And my friend Bassil [assumed
spelling] that introduced me
to these guys, his great
grandfather to my surprise was one
of the most influential Sufi
Sheiks in Aleppian history.
So he made the call and they
kind of vouched for me to come in
and allowed me to make this album.
So I'm going to show you
what this sounds like.
It's one of my favorite recordings.
And so it was two different
recording sessions.
It was like a trial run.
They want to see if I can handle it.
And then there was the second one
where they kind of let me come in.
So this is called "Fasel
Kesmet Al Sawi".
I'm going to play in a bridge
version because it's a very wrong--
this is essentially a prayer.
And I'm going to tell you
after this why we record.
[ Singing ]
To tell you a little
bit about these guys,
the founder of this
group was 15 years old,
and on this recording he's 17.
And the guys-- the main
voice you hear, he's 20.
So everyone was between 15 and 55
and the 15 year old, his teacher was
in his 90s and past away and
left him a pile of manuscripts
from the mid 18th century.
And so, they took these manuscripts
and they had to do it outside
of the Sufi lodge because they
weren't practicing these modernly
and we're doing it in this courtyard
and that's what we're listening to.
So--
[ Singing ]
In rock terms, that's
called the hit, right?
I love that record.
And as I said my daughter was four
months old when that was recorded.
So that was her lullaby
when she couldn't sleep.
I'd throw on the Sufi recordings
and make her go to sleep.
So, before I end with the
slideshow, there's a--
it's really opt that we're
in the Library of Congress.
All of these traditions are
heavily academically researched,
all of them.
And as someone that's highly
inquisitive, I couldn't find
that much on where the
research into this stuff.
And so, what I kind of found is
once I started to really try to dive
into it and figure out where to get
this, this whole building is nothing
but information and all
these academic depositories
and repositories all over the
earth, there's a lot of information.
And for someone like me that's an
experiential learner, it's difficult
to jump in to a lot of these
books that are just information.
I wanted a story.
Where is the story about this
or where is the story
about the Syrian Church?
And I could read all
the details about it
but it wasn't hitting me the
way that lyrics do, essentially.
And so, when I decided to
start putting my records out,
I wanted to tell the
story of the communities,
not just the information
about the communities.
And so, all of these records are
extremely expensive to produce.
I say that because each individual
record has to be representative
of not just the music but of the
community that this is a recording
of and it's not my decision.
I have people.
Everyone on the recording
has to agree that this--
not just represents them but who
they are and where they come from.
So there's always native script.
Since this is Sufi, this is Arabic.
This photo was taken by my friend
that that I had told him we
should get off the computer with.
He took this photo personally.
And then for those like
me, there's always a map.
There has to be a map that
sits the modern country
of Syria with current boundaries.
And that's what brought me
to the Library of Congress,
for the Armenian album which
I'm getting ready to show you.
How do you delicately draw the
boundaries of historical Armenia?
That's what I came to live on,
to figure out how to solve,
which gets me to my second album
which is the "Forty Martyrs" album.
It is-- I went deep on this one.
Anytime you add a fold,
it gets significantly more
pricey, so I put in three folds.
So, triple gate fold.
The punk rock at me has always want
to do this and never been able to.
So now that I'm in charge and
I'm losing money permanently,
so let's just lose
a lot of it, right?
So, the native script here,
these are actually the notes
that we were taking while the
recording was happening and all
of the photography is my
photography from inside.
Metaphorically speaking
that background of all
of these is a photograph
I took in 2002
of the ancient City
of Ani, and map again.
This one is the shortest
album, and Armenian--
the Armenian community is--
and I learned all of this
as I'm doing the research.
I know none of this
until it comes time
to figure out, "OK,
what am I doing?"
Is the tradition of
[foreign language].
Did I say it right?
So I'm learning and
pronouncing things correctly.
Inside the Forty Martyrs
Church, there's a wall
of all these different stone
carvings, which are crosses
and that tradition is actually
on UNESCO's defined list
of intangible heritage.
And I didn't have enough
music for a two-sided album.
So for this one, I put a silkscreen
of one of the oldest carvings
on the backside of the album
and this is a 16th
century stone carving,
that's the backside of this.
So what we're getting
ready to do is,
I'm going to show you
some photographs
and play you some Armenian chanting
but I want to read a poem first.
With all of these, this
is not a solo effort.
I have to rope people in.
I am clearly not the
expert, just the enthusiast.
So I went to New York and I
sat down with one of the heads
of the Armenian theological seminary
and he told me about this poem
which was written in 1947 when
they were trying to-- when they--
when Russia was trying to get
Armenians to move back to Armenia
and this guy's older
brother, he was at--
this guy is a survivor of World
War I, of the Armenian catastrophes
on World War I and had relocated,
built his life back up in Aleppo
and was thinking about moving
back to Armenia with his brothers
but his brothers discouraged
him from coming.
So in his torments to figure out
whether he should stay or go,
he wrote this poem
called "Farewell Aleppo."
I'm going to read it for
you before I play the music
and the photograph I put
on here almost everything
in this photograph
is totally destroyed.
It's either ruins or just
not in existence anymore.
So this is "Farewell Aleppo".
"You are in Arab City,
my honorable birthplace.
My eyes opened and I saw you,
I knew there was no other city.
My second fatherland,
with your Syrian people.
You became the good
protector to the Armenian.
You gave us bread and shelter.
We have lived always together,
as brothers Armenian to Arab.
We have worked always together,
as a Syria without guile.
The day of our separation is near, O
alter of the light of my childhood.
We shall ever remember you, O
alter of the hope of my childhood.
Etchmiadzin's carillon rang out,
calling her children to her.
I am parting from you with
love, City of Aleppo farewell."
And, that is the poem for all of us
since the city is essentially
destroyed.
And so, I'm going to play--
I'm going to show you
guys some photographs.
They're minimally captions.
I do it that way because that's
the way I experienced it.
I kind of knew what I was looking
at but really and I want people
to see the beauty of the country.
And a lot of people ask me,
"Why don't you do a before
and after slideshow?"
And it is because it
is very difficult
to erase the memory of
something destroyed.
I always talk about going to see
my grandfather at the funeral home.
It's hard to lose the memory of
the way he looks in his casket.
It's really difficult and it
takes time for me to think back
to when I was six and we
were playing in the yard.
So this is the yard.
This is not the casket, which brings
me to-- it's a very symbolic day.
Three years ago today,
the archbishop
that housed me was abducted
by terrorist and he's gone.
And so there's little
information about it at the end.
And so, as you can hear, I'm
extremely emotional about all
of this because it's so heavy.
So, this is the "Forty Martyrs"
album that we're going to play
and then I'm going to
show you some photographs.
And then, if there's any time, you
guys can ask me official questions
or hit me up in the lobby.
[ Singing ]
So, clearly, the war wages on.
Some insight the day that
the Forty Martyrs album came
out the church was bombed.
The structures that were in the
photographs are still there.
It came in the courtyard.
So the scope of all of this and this
archive of information that I have,
the information is the same but the
context changes on a weekly basis.
And so what I'm trying to do is
go around, put my record player
and my stories and my pictures
and just expose for the sake
of knowledge, what this place
was and the only reason I went
from the very beginning and I've
been like this my whole life
from my bands to my music to
this, to my photography is
to show the thread of how we
are the same as humans as oppose
to how we were different and I
hope you got some of that today
and I thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: Jason
I want to thank you.
>> This has been a present
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.com.